when you have something to say and uh
and today I'm celebrating also the uh
the fact that uh uh finally volume four
has has actually started to appear in
bookstores and uh so uh uh in case like
you
know
uh the publicity people haven't done
their job uh you know this is presumably
at Stanford bookstore um and uh it's uh
it's not the real volume four of the art
of computer program but it's it's it's
very close to what the real volume for
will be and our plan is to is to put out
128 Pages uh at a time about twice a
year and uh and so U what I'm talking
about today is something that's going
into the uh you know number three that's
going to come out in in summer um and uh
uh it's something I learned about in
January uh no I learned about in
February but it was it it was the
preprint was was put on the web on the
10th of January uh here's
the Here's the the uh the source of what
I'm of of what I'm going talking about
it's a paper
that titled was Crossings and nestings
and matching with partitions my title
for the paper is integer partitions and
set partitions a marvelous con uh
connection because uh I got very excited
when I saw this uh in fact this is my
birthday January 10th um and the authors
um uh there are five authors and
um
uh this this is something that came out
of a visit that rich Richard Stanley
made to China last last summer um and uh
and so uh and so he's one of the he's
the person I know and then Bill Chen is
is director of a center for
commentator at nanka University and
these other people and uh and uh the
only other thing I can mention is that
Katherine Yan is actually uh in America
at at Texas A&M and she's got one of the
greatest email addresses I I uh I I know
cyan uh Katherine Yan now um okay so
anyway this paper excited me for other
reasons than than than cute email
addresses um and uh uh I'll I'll try to
uh um you know go through it the idea is
amazingly simple it's something that I
kicking myself for not not seeing in
the' 60s um because it doesn't use
anything that I didn't know for for many
many years and I don't think I'm going
to live that many more years in my
life that will well I mean in anybody's
life that you're going to find U uh uh
great new things out about integer
partitions or or set partitions these
these things have been studied for for
ages and so what what left is there
fairly simple that's that can be
exciting that's still that's still go
but but anyway uh uh if you're not
excited about it anyway then I have to
kick myself again because uh when I saw
this paper I added uh a page and a half
to uh uh the next part of of volume four
uh you know the fical 3 that's coming
out in the summer um and that meant um
uh I mean I was already way over my page
budget so so I decided but I just
couldn't let leave this result out of
the book and I added a page and a half
not only that but you know when I a
paper that has four Chinese four Chinese
authors that I've never heard that I've
never met before that means a lot more
work for me because I put everybody's
Chinese name in the index and so it you
know it means lots of extra work to to
correspondents to find out how to do the
character character codes and everything
else so you can see that at least
externally there's some reason to to
believe that I that I love this result
now um uh so what is the uh what is the
what is the connection and well it's
it's now exercise 27 in uh in what's
going to be uh section 7215 of the art
of computer programming which and that's
going to be fascal
um uh uh three let's see I must have
that page somewhere where is the page we
have exercise 27 on this page 44 well
maybe I didn't bring that
page
um no big deal
um um before I okay so
uh I guess I better tell you what set
partitions are and what and and what
what integer partitions are um so
example of a set partition is um uh
let's say I have the numbers 1 to n and
and I can have a and and a set partition
might be like
135 uh and then I put a vertical line to
say I'm in a new part of the partition
27 48 9 6 this means I take this the
numbers 1 to n and I group this case
it's it's partitioned into four blocks
um and uh so one and three and five are
in the same block you you know and two
and seven are are another block of the
partition and so on so a set partition
is a way to take a set and and partition
it into subsets uh dis joint subsets and
uh and it's it's the same as saying we
have an equivalence relation you say one
is equivalent to three and and five two
is equivalent to seven and so on the uh
any equivalence relation partitions the
set into things that are that are in the
same block uh the same are equivalent to
each other uh so it's a hugely important
Concept in mathematics uh then uh an
integer partition is a way to represent
an integer as a sum of of other integers
um and uh so an integer partition for
example uh here uh the the sizes of the
blocks make an integer partition so 9 is
equal to 3 + 2 + 3 + 1 with the integer
practition we don't consider the order
uh I
mean composition is an ordered partition
but an uned
partition we would say it's equal 3 3 2
1 we usually uh when we give a partition
we usually give the give the sizes of
the of the parts um in uh by sorting
them increasing or decreasing order okay
but the set partition is a different
concept and when you when you have a a
paper in mathematics that where it talks
about partitions in the title uh the
odds are about 70 to 30 that it's uh
that it's about integer partitions and
30% that it's about set partitions and
uh and and there there always been this
U this kind of a uh you know the word
partition uh uh used for both Concepts
we never changed English to to to think
of another word for for the concept of a
set partition um and um uh in fact the
integer partitions and set partitions
are extremes of uh are sort of the
opposite ends of the general idea of a
multiset partition so so a multiset
partition uh for example I could have a
multis set that has 1 one 2 3 3 3 4 5
this is some multi set okay um and now
um I could imagine dividing it up into
into blocks U whose whose Union with the
proper multiplicities is a set now if I
have a if the multi set happens to be
one one one one one one11 one one its
partitions are integer partitions and if
the multi set is 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 89 its
partitions are are set partitions so so
the the extreme case of of multiset
partitions at one hand you have integer
partition at the other hand you have set
partition um but but usually the the
techniques that you use for one of uh
you know you you put one hat on for
those and you and you put another hat on
when you're working on sep parti what's
the what I'm going to do today is I'm
going to describe um a one to one
correspondence between every set
partition and and a sequence of integer
partitions and the and the SE quence of
integer partitions is U is is what I
wish I had page 44 to show you but I
don't um it's um it's uh
uh but it's it's probably better for me
to to to write it down so it's a
sequence of inte partition you usually
uh uh high power mathematicians use uh
Lambda to to to stand for a partition
and so it's a sequence of partitions uh
uh Lambda 1 Lambda 2 to in this case
Lambda 2N where where n is the number of
elements in the set that we're
partitioning so
um and uh and the idea is that uh uh uh
each of these is an integer
partition and U and in fact Lambda 0 is
zero and Lambda 2N is also zero um so so
it gets interesting in the
middle and um the uh
and the uh key concept is that we're
going to call it a
vacillating tableau loop I didn't make
up this
term but the the loop means that it sort
of Loops back to zero again and um and
the Tableau you'll see why they they
chose that word um and I think they
chose the word vacillating because you
know at the time they were doing this
research uh
uh vacillating was one of the concepts
in the presidential election you know
the people were talking about so some
candidates being more vacillating than
others or something like this so so that
was a word in the in the news so they
thought of it but anyway um that's their
word for it and the idea is that Lambda
um k +
1 um Lambda K is equal to the previous
Sky Plus um uh minus1 to the K time e
sub TK where e is an elementary change
to the
partition um e e0 is all zeros which
means the partition doesn't
change uh oh oh TK uh is is U is between
zero and N uh E1 is
um uh one and then all zeros E2 is 0 one
all zeros and E n is is all zeros to n
one uh so uh so we have a sequence of
integers you know T T1 T2 up to
t2n um which uh which describe the
change we're going to make to this
vacillating Tableau loop at and each
time we have a partition we're going to
change it by by changing just one of its
components
either maybe we won't change it at all
if we have if is zero then we don't
change anything but if TK is nonzero
then uh you know U if it's if it's two
or something then uh then we change the
second uh element of the
partition um now now the partitions are
supposed to be uh in in decreasing or
I'll give many examples and and uh and
starting in about 3 minutes from now I'm
going to ask you to stop me whenever you
don't understand but I know you can't
possibly understand yet but but in 3
minutes I I'll have I'll get to a point
where you know where I'm going to I'm
going to make I'm going to start wanting
to be sure that I'm in sync with
everybody else's on this idea so so so
notationally um it's described this way
it says that uh uh you know uh we we
take away an element maybe then we
possibly add an element then we possibly
take one away then we possibly add and
so on now we have to we can't use any
any such sequence because uh uh it might
turn out that that we can't add
something uh and and we no longer have a
partition uh I mean the things W the
things won't be in order anymore because
Lambda K is going to be is going to be a
sequence of elements a A1
ak2 uh and so on U that are that are uh
sorted they're going to be getting
smaller and smaller and smaller uh uh
and always uh non- negative so so uh the
idea here is that uh uh certain
sequences are going to work in certain
certain arms now
um uh I uh exercise 27 uh asks first of
all for the reader to find all the
oscillating all the vacillating Tableau
Loops that uh uh in the case n equals
4 um Nal 4 you know uh uh is small
enough that um that you can do it easily
and large enough that uh it's not
trivial um and the number of partitions
of a set of four elements is 15 so you
have so there better be 15 vacillating
uh Tableau loops and uh uh here's the
answer um
uh which I'm where I'm um Can Can we can
you see that yeah Zoom that's very good
so so so take the first one all zeros
that's certainly a tableau Loop nothing
happens right uh and then here's here's
one it you know it gets to be a one I
I've listed them in in dictionary order
here so it gets to be a one uh at this
point um that that must be in an even
numbered position because uh because we
can only increase when we're at an even
numbered position we decrease when when
we're at odd numbered position um uh so
uh these are all the all the cases and
and so
really there's only two uh
uh cases where we where we get past
zeros and ones and here's a case where
we have a partition that has two ones in
it and here's a partition that has a two
in it all right but but uh it's kind of
a a tricky condition that you know you
you if you if you try to play around
with this uh then you um um will uh find
out that you better look ahead if you're
going to get back to zero at the end um
so uh well when when n gets bigger and
bigger it gets lot the the partitions in
in the middle get much more interesting
as we're going to see but uh anyway
that's the definition of a vacillating
tableau Loop and I want to before I go
into it I want to I want to describe uh
one more thing is a convenient notation
for set partitions uh so set partition
uh uh one way is to run the blocks like
this as I did but another nice way is
what they call a restricted growth
string um a restricted growth sequence
and um and the idea is that you that you
give in uh symbols uh uh first you say
what class is is is one in then two then
three then four and so on up to n and uh
and you start with zero so one is we'll
call this block zero block one block two
block three and we start with zero um
and then two uh is in in Block one and
uh in a restricted growth sequence uh uh
well let me write it out first and and
uh so three is in Block zero four is in
Block two five is in Block zero six is
in block three seven is in Block uh one
uh8 and nine are both in Block two okay
so this restricted growth sequence is
another way to talk about this set
partition 135 2748 96 is are people
understand that you look at this you can
see oh yeah 1 three and five are
equivalent they got the same number two
and seven are equivalent um uh you know
four 8 and N are equivalent because they
have the same number now it's called
restricted growth sequence U the rule is
that if you
if um whenever you choose a number for
the first time uh it has to be just one
bigger than the ones you've seen before
so after so after I've after I've got
after I've done 0102 my next choice has
to be 0 1 two or three but I but I
couldn't go to four at this point
because three hasn't occurred yet after
this again I can go 0 one2 3 after this
012 three now I could introduce a four
if I wanted
to okay so that's a restricted growth
sequence and and the and every every
restricted growth sequence uh is a set
partition and and every set partition is
is a respct grow sequence so it's it's a
it's a easy way to St to deal with them
inside a computer U to work with
restrict and so that's what I did on
this chart here I showed the different
restricted growth sequences for Nal 4
012 3 0122 and and I put next to it U
the uh uh the vacillating Tableau Loop
that that we're going to show uh
corresponds to these so I have to get it
uh I have to get a connection between
these things um and uh uh uh so the the
in the rest of my lecture I'm going to
explain why there's a one toone
correspondence between um uh set
partitions and these T these these Loops
of of ordinary integer partitions um and
then why this has a really extraordinary
con consquences that sort of
mindboggling okay now um uh the the
construction that I need is based on a
couple of ideas that were in volume
three of the art of computer programming
and the first the first nice idea uh due
to uh uh
Kaplansky uh and then uh uh he he worked
with John Ruden during the during the
second world war U says that there's a
one toone correspond it's a really
simple way to to to uh uh uh to
represent set partitions uh in terms of
Rooks on a triangular chessboard anybody
here who doesn't know what what a rook
is in a chessboard so okay so uh so here
uh we have a
um uh triangular chessboard and uh we
got we place Rooks in it uh that can
attack each other that means that we
have uh
we don't have any two Rooks in the same
row we don't have any two Rooks in the
same column and that's the and and every
way there is to put uh Rooks into a
triangle chessboard corresponds to
exactly one uh set partition and uh I
mean you uh you don't have
to you can't actually place too many
Rooks um uh and uh he don't put put any
any down at all that corresponds to a
set partition and and so this so and the
rule is extremely simple
um uh in fact I I'm going to actually
you know I didn't know when I wrote
volume 3 that I was going to be talking
about uh Tableau uh uh when I when I got
into volume four so I'm I'm going to tip
the Triangular board this way but the
Rooks will still still go on so uh let
let me show you the uh the way I
represent that at in in a triangular
array and um uh I I um I draw the num I
I put the numbers 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8
n along the edge and now um if I want to
say one is is um uh is equivalent to
three I put an X in in uh column one in
row three and then three is equivalent
to five I put an x uh 3 to five I always
go to the next one that uh uh that it's
that it's equivalent
to um so five doesn't have any you know
five is is is the is the top guy in his
block so nothing there two goes to seven
so there's going to be a an X up here um
I try to draw some lines that make make
it a little easier uh then what do I do
for four four goes to eight and eight
goes to nine okay so now I I've put uh
at most one rook in every column at most
one rook in every row which row which
Rook did I put in a row well if if I'm
not the the smallest in the block The
Rook in that row is is your neighbor uh
to the left in the block um what what
Rook do I put in the column if you're
not the the biggest in your in your
block that's your neighbor to the right
in in your block okay so by looking at
the by looking at the Rooks I know what
set partition I
have um and uh uh the uh so so anyway
here we are with a with a connection
between uh uh set partitions and Rooks
and now um that's going to be uh the key
to our uh our integer partitions that's
coming up next well right after this uh
part of uh right after the page um where
I had this picture of the Rooks saw the
next page starts the section of of
volume three that talks about Tableau
and these are
fascinating uh concept that that seems
to have tremendous applications in in uh
uh mathematical physics and many other
things because the because it relates to
basic properties of part of permutations
and uh and and a tableau is is uh
uh uh an array of of integers that uh
looks like this um uh for example uh
it's increasing in rows and and
increasing in the columns and it's and
it's uh these rows are are are are are
left Justified so so the the shape of
the Tableau is a partition uh this you
know here's a partition 64
311 and that's a partition of 16 and and
the number here I put the numbers 1 to
16 into a tableau and one of the one of
the uh uh most uh uh
uh I don't know amazing fundamental and
so on
the uh
operations was discovered it's now it's
called the Robinson Shen stead algorithm
um and I so I started out that part of
volume 3 talking about how to insert a
new element into a tableau I guess I
don't have an eight in this one um so so
uh there's there's a a um
uh cud
algorithm that
um uh
uh by which I can insert a new guy into
that into into a tableau uh somebody who
isn't already there and uh and it works
like this
um
uh I Tred to put it in the first row uh
and
uh um in such a way that the first row
is not going to nobody's going to get
bigger in the first row so uh I can't
put it on top I you know the one eight
is bigger than one so I I I want
anything to get bigger but I could put
it on top of the nine because the nine
would get smaller go to an eight um I
couldn't put it on 12 because not
because then it wouldn't would be out of
order so I so I change the nine I put an
eight and now I and now I insert nine
into the rest of it um uh before so so
the nine is going to fit here in place
of the 10 the 10 is going to place here
uh fit here in place of the 13 and the
13 is going to fall on the next row it's
going to fit uh to the right in place of
an Infinity that was sort of sitting
there um so I so I put in the element
eight and that that bumped the nine and
the and the 10 and the 13 down and this
bumping algorithm is uh is easy to learn
and and uh has these properties that U I
explained in the uh um in in this
algorithm on page 49 of volume 3 uh this
is you know this bumping algorithm um is
is given there and and and and proved
and then uh the uh the beautiful thing
is is that also U we can go we can go
backwards this algorithm has an inverse
somebody tells me uh uh Delete the
element that was in that was in this
position there's only way there's only
one way we could have filled that uh
that 13 the 13 had to come from the
previous line and uh uh and so it would
have to have been displaced by a 10 then
the 10 had to go up to the second line
and had have been displaced by nine and
the nine had to come from the first line
and so um uh the eight had to been the
thing that we inserted other words you
can this so with with every Tableau we
have an algorithm putting something in
the Tableau and we can and and and if
somebody tells you where which which was
the new guy filled up in the in the
thing you can undo it and figure out
where you came from again uh that's the
co that's the the theorem that um is is
on page 51 of volume 3 it says there's a
onetoone correspondence between all
permutations and the set of ordered
pairs of tableaus having the same shape
um and uh uh the actual um uh idea is
um uh works it works also with um uh in
more gener under more General conditions
instead of a permutation we have any any
two line any any twool line array of
stuff where we say q1 uh is less than Q2
or less than qn and p1's are all are all
different and a permutation is the case
where the q's are 1 2 3 4 up to n and
the P's are just the the the numbers in
some other order um so here's an here's
an example of this generalized
permutation it it would be 1 3 5 68 uh
in two line over 7 2
953 and uh and in in the book I I go
through playby play uh uh you start with
an empty Tableau and we insert the first
guy seven and uh and then we put in Q
the place where we inserted it then I
insert the next guy which is two well
two is going to bump the seven down and
uh and uh and then I I put a three below
it uh where I in the place that that
just be just became filled okay now for
nine what's going to happen well nine is
going to fit in the front row of
two followed by nine still leaves a
tableau that's good so then I can put
the nine here and the five goes in there
next I insert a five at the left five is
not going to fit at the end of the first
row it's going to bump the nine down but
the nine will fit there so I so I
continue and and so I have this
algorithm of inserting a new guy and and
bumping and and uh um uh the uh uh this
means that given any two-line array like
this um I I can fill I I can find two
Tableau that are of the same shape every
time I'm putting something in on in Q
I'm putting in a bigger element that
what was before so it's definitely a
tableau here and this bumping algorithm
keeps keeps the P's uh as as as as
Tableau so uh every permutation gives us
these two Tableau and you can also go
backward cuz if I have to go back and
say what permutation caused this well I
look at the highest element in Q that
was eight so I said oh okay this this
seven must have come from somewhere so
the seven is going to is so so I used
the deletion algorithm and the deletion
algorithm says the only way I could have
got from that is by popping the three
out of this of this P Tableau so I pop
the three out and I get back to here and
then and then I take off the six and I
pop pop the N you know the nine is going
to pop out the five and so that so I can
reconstruct the original
13568 72 953 from these two
Tableau okay now that is the that is uh
the amazing uh uh correspondence of
Robinson and
ganstead that um um is going to be the
key to what we do now
um
so um uh because what I'm going to do
is I'm going to I'm going to think of
this uh uh
here I have my my uh set partition
represented uh by Rooks and uh uh and I
write that as a a sequence um where I
say you know the the let's see which way
do I want to do I want to do it page
70 yeah my on okay so um I'll say 1 3
27 um 3 5
48 8
UM in other words one successor is three
two successor is seven three successor
is five four successor is eight five
doesn't have a successor
six six doesn't NE not here does seven
eight has nine as a successor so here's
a two-line array that describes the
position of these
Rooks and I can now go and um uh get a
one one correspondence between these uh
this two line array and um uh my uh and
and two Tableau but instead we we we do
it um more tricky way and we we for and
and and so here's my uh let's see Sean
how how large can you make this TR try
to go for the max yeah perfect okay now
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
I've got not I've got a set partition of
nine elements I'm I'm going to I'm going
to do 18 steps I'm going to get eight
I'm going to make a vacillating tableau
Loop of size 2N which is 18 in this case
um and uh I'm I'm going to um um
uh uh walk around the edge 0 1 2 3 4
these tiny little numbers here uh and
I'm going to do an 18-step process and
and and and wherever I am I'm going to
look at the rectangle above the point
where I am so I start out and um and uh
the first from 0er to one it's always uh
uh is always trivial in fact you might
think it's really stupid the way I
Define a vacillating tableau Loop
because I'm saying that Lambda one
I I said I said that Lambda 1 has to be
equal to Lambda 0 minus E sub T1 and uh
but but Lambda 0 is zero so I can't
possibly take anything away from it so
so Lambda 1 is always zero and similarly
Lambda 2N minus one is always zero so it
seems like you know I'm wasting a lot of
energy by writing these extra zeros here
but makes the it makes the uh things uh
cleaner and more General it's why we why
we did it but not but now when when I go
um uh on the next step here from step
one to step two now my rectangle all of
a sudden gained a
rook and so at that point I I I I put 1
three into here's my Rook it's it's in
column one and and Row three um and so I
um and then uh then I mve to step two
and at step two I still have one three
but but then I when I go over to step
three I move to the right right here I
pick up another Rook so then I got 1
three and two um
7 and I and I walk along here and and
and uh when I go up the next step I lose
the 1 three and and and only the 27
remains because this Rook has now you
know I I'm always taking the rectangle
based on where I am so I've lost a rook
at this point when I went from from from
step four to step five here this little
four to this five and here I gain a rook
here here here I don't you know it stays
the same here I gain a rook here I lose
a rook okay but now I keep track of I
keep track of two line arrays of what
Rooks I uh what Rooks I currently
um are currently in this rectangle to my
left you get it l all right so so so I'm
wondering a along the Ed along the edge
here when I'm making a step upward is
where I could lose a
rook if I'm making a step or if I'm
making a step to the right I could gain
a rook so so the total number of Rooks
is vacillating in this
way exactly the way the way I want it
okay so uh uh and and I get a two line
array at every Point showing what the
Rooks are so um I can put the two I I so
every two line array can be represented
by by equal Tableau by equal shaped
Tableau p and Q so so like when I had 13
this was my P and q 13 okay um but now
when I put the 27 in there um I
um uh then I have to you know decide how
to insert the seven uh um there's going
to be a two on the right and in this
case uh it turned out that uh it's
better
uh although I could have changed all the
notation it's better to to use
decreasing order on the P Tableau and
increasing order on the Q Tableau so I'm
I'm going to do the same bumping
algorithms before but I'm going to make
the Tableau go decreasing and instead of
increasing uh the same algorithm you
just change less less than to greater
than all the way through uh uh and uh uh
that's probably why it took it it took
so many years before people thought of
this idea because now things are this
this simple thing using uh decreasing
order in p and increasing in Q makes
makes these things all of a sudden uh uh
uh easier to to uh to um notate and and
work with so so the seven is is then
instead of making three followed by
seven I'm going to have a seven bumping
the three down and and I get this array
and then um uh and then the um the um uh
I lose the one three uh so at that point
the three disappears and
um from the
pay uh you know we just take it out and
and uh the two displaces the
one so I delete two from the Q array I
mean I delete the the cell in a second
row from the Q aray which means means
that the one has to come off the top and
and that's uh okay so uh uh the process
continues um at even numbered steps we
might add a a new element when five
comes in it fits like this uh on odd
numbered steps we might lose an element
so a step nine uh here uh the five goes
away um and the and the three uh pops up
because there was a 3 five that's
disappearing uh so here's the in other
words we have this complete description
of the uh of this set partition uh as a
sequence of Tableau that's growing
shrinking growing
shrinking um and
um uh now now we throw away the numbers
and we only look at the
shapes so the shapes are partitions so
so the partition is uh you know I didn't
show step one and one so so actually if
I if I if I if I give you just the
partitions it's Z you know we start with
0 0 then at step two we have have one
the shape is one here I have a shape one
one you know one row and another row
then I'm back to one here I have a shape
two two 2 one one one one one one one
one one one one okay now so I've got
this set of partitions here the sequence
of partitions here that's
vacillating comes back to
zero um and
um uh the sequence uh has this property
by the way that
um uh we
can we know when
we've when the thing stays the same it
stays the same if there's I mean an
odd-numbered step stays the same if
there's nothing in the column if there
even numbered steps
there's nothing in the row something
anyway something like that we can we can
tell by looking at this which rows were
filled and which columns were
filled um but we can also tell exactly
exactly where they are and that's the
and that's the amazing thing I I I could
figure out uh the P's and the q's uh
just by knowing the shapes and um the
reason is
um
uh
well of course the reason is simple um
because of of
the of this magical Robinson shed stead
process um so let's suppose that I that
I didn't know um what's happening when
I'm going from Step SE step seven uh U
um I'm going to fill in
the I'm going to show how to fill in the
cues and suppose I got up to step seven
and I know that and I know that um that
I have two three here in Q and I'm going
to go to step 8 uh and uh if we if I go
up to my diagram here from um from 7 to
8 is is this step here which is adding
adding an element right um but all I
know all I'm told is that
um is that the Tableau gained a new
element down
here um but what new element uh could it
possibly have
gained
um uh when I'm going from when I'm going
from 7 to 8 uh uh because um uh it's
column four so so it has to be a four
the only you know the new element that
gets added when I add an element is is
when I'm doing eight I'm I always adding
a four and if I'm doing 10 I'd be adding
a five and if I you know if I'm doing
step 2K I'm getting I'm adding a k so so
uh uh it's easy to to go from 7 to 8 and
figure out this must be 2 3 4 now what
about step nine step nine I'm told that
that the shape now goes like
this so what what what is Q going to be
at after step nine all I'm told is that
the shape that the partition has now
lost this element in the first
row well
um uh you see that's the deletion
algorithm for Tableau it says just
delete the element three and so it so
the two inforce
day um that was that was maybe too easy
uh I mean to delete the three is easier
what if I had deleted Instead This four
what would have
happened well then
you see the four would have had to been
B would have had to been bumped by
somebody in the previous row and it
would have been it wouldn't have been
bumped by the two because it couldn't
have been four3 so it had to be two four
so so the four would have had to had to
had had to be bumped by the three and
the three would would have popped out
the top so so in general I can go
through just from the shapes and I can
figure out what the cues
are and uh go going in forward order and
but same same argument if you think
about it going backward you can fill in
all the peas going from the end to to
the
beginning um and so uh it but actually
as long as you know what that that you
know that the three got got bounced out
at this point uh when nine was added
then then you know exactly which Rook it
was in in in row uh in the row that that
that we that we're going up here U we're
going from 8 to 9 we're we're going from
row four to row five uh to row three not
to row row four to row five um so so
that says that it must have been a 35
there must have been a rook in 35 so so
so so the guy that so so in other words
somebody gives you a sequence of of
these integer partitions then um you you
don't have to work with the P's at all
you can just suffices to do with the q's
uh you can um um uh if you're at step 2K
you added a new element just put K in
the in the new position that just showed
up in the partition if you're at step 2K
+ 1 and you're deleting an element uh uh
you take the place in the partition that
you want to get rid of you you you you
use your deletion algorithm and see what
pops out the top and that's the that's
where the Rook was in position K in in
row
K so this tells you what where the Rooks
are in each in every row so that's the
that's the uh the one one correspondence
between integer partitions and set
partitions every every set partition
gives me this sequence of integer
partitions from which I can reconstruct
the set partition
uniquely okay so that is the now now the
U uh for some of the amazing
consequences of this result okay so uh
and most of the consequences that I know
are uh fall from the the uh idea of
taking the transpose or the conjugate of
integer partition so if I have a if I
have an integer partition let's take uh
you know what was the one I had a minute
ago uh uh we said uh six
4 6 4 31 1 so 1 2 3 4 5
311 um
it has a conjugate so you know this is
Lambda then it has transpose the
conjugate is uh just like you do with
with uh taking the transpose of a matrix
so it has six in the First Column and
then
four and then
three um and then one one okay so here's
the
533 211 is the conjugate of so you know
643 1 1 conjugate is equal to 533
okay
now um uh obvious idea Le leads to lots
of of startling properties of integer
partitions for example the number of
integer partitions with largest part six
is also equal to the number of
partitions that have exactly six
parts
um but now we got a a vacillating
tableau Loop Lambda 1 Lambda 2 up to
Lambda 2 N
um uh we can form its
transpose
transposes um and lo and behold these
are also form a a vacillating tableau
Loop
because if you if you add one ele if if
you add an element to a to a partition
uh you're adding an element to its
conjugate if you're taking an element
away from a partition you're taking an
element away from its conjugate so so we
have a one to one correspondence
between uh set partitions and their
duels so was call is the Dual set
partition so so so this corresponds to
some set partition pi and this
corresponds to the Dual of Pi whatever
that means okay so so now we have an
operation on set partitions
uh that takes every set partition into
some other set partition that is that is
uh uh well there it is it's toel and um
here's where here's where the uh uh uh
the the amazing things start to happen
let's first take let's take a look um at
U uh at at at uh couple of things first
um uh so so in order if you want to play
around with this I've got a computer
program that I put on the web called
vacillate and you just go to my homepage
and then click on downloadable programs
and you you know you get the program and
I just put it I just put it there it's
uh it you have to you have to
uh you have to use cweb uh which is easy
to install um um but anyway I have this
way of of writing programs that um me
that I can get a lot my program's done
much faster than anybody else I know so
so uh but here I said I wrote I write
the following code in an awful hurry so
there was no time to you like I wrote
the fining code in awful hurry um anyway
it but it's all there and it gives you a
chance to play around with um uh with
things and here for example is the
partition that I did in my I I I have a
I put in a file this restricted growth
string which is which is is for this uh
partition here 0102 03111 122 all right
and then um it
will um it will tell you
uh what the partition is at each
step uh and what the rows what the p
andq uh entries are if you know you can
shut you can shut verbose off and you
don't get all this but it tells you you
know if you want to know what the PS and
q's are it tells you uh what they are
and then it tells you The Duel uh so
what's the Duel of this partition
um uh it is um 2 three 4 6 7 8 nine okay
well what you got 1 two 3 4 five six
whoops I I made it too big
sorry okay
um so um it says its dual is 0112
um so that says you know um I could call
it
03 21 one
so one is one and five are equivalent
two and three are equivalent three is
equivalent to
8 um eight and four is equivalent to
seven
um uh three is is at the top there um
two is is the top eight and N are
equivalent oh eight and N what's going
on let me um let me scratch that
up
oh here we go
um I need uh graph paper
aha
okay
I found out to my great surprise
that the theory group at Stanford
computer science department does not
have a stock of graph paper tablets I
had to go down to the graphics group
down on the third floor okay so um
anyway we got
9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2
1 um and
um
right and I'm saying
that one is equivalent to five
who it's not that
funny
okay one
yeah yeah all right okay
so okay so one is equivalent to five I
put a rook there
uh two is equivalent to three three is
equivalent to
8 eight is equivalent to 9 four is
S I think that's it 1 2 3 4 5 1 2 3 4 5
six nope I'm missing
something 3 1 1 2 to 3 3 to 8 8 to 9
excuse
me so five
is two three four no I'm I'm I'm right I
should have only five Rooks because I
started with five Rooks there I number
of Rooks stays the same in fact uh what
stays the same under Duality um uh the
number of Rooks in every row stays the
same under Duality number of Rooks in
every column stays the same under
Duality um because I I got a a rook in
this column only if I if I increased the
partition when I went there so so I've
got five Rooks of in the same columns as
I had before and in the same rows as I
had
before
now
um
the
main the main thing that is known about
Tableau however it it which is the
wonderful thing about
these about them is that the number of
rows in the
Tableau the the size of of the first row
in the Tableau is the length of the
longest increasing subsequence of the
permutation that you started
with um and uh this is and the number of
of I mean the number number of columns
and the and the number of of rows is the
is the length of the
longest
U decreasing subsequence so so um uh
what what that means is that um I've got
uh when I'm looking at
a a uh uh any one of these any one of
these rectangles that I've got that that
I'm working is as I'm as I'm crawl along
the edge here and I and I I have these
these rectangles um the Rooks that I'm
seeing in the rectangle uh correspond to
a two-line array and a uh an increasing
sequence of length four corresponds to a
bunch of of x's that that that go up the
decreasing sequence corresponds to a
bunch of xes that that go
down and when you transpose and get the
dual every increasing sequence uh uh I
mean the rows and columns get switched
around and so that it says that every
time I have one of these squares here
that had well this this is here here's a
here's a case this Square uh I mean it's
not this rectangle uh has has two Rooks
in it um and it's it's a decrease right
so I look in the Duel at those same at
the same place it's an
increase and and and the theorem is
there exists a an an increasing set of K
Rooks in one of these rectangles if and
only if there's a decreasing set of of K
Rooks in the Dual rectangle in in a
rectangle in that same rectangle of the
duo now what does that mean as far as
set partitions are concerned well um
when we one one way to another way to um
uh to represent set partitions in fact
this was uh very popular in Japan going
back uh 400 years more than 400 years is
to is is to connect uh the ele the
elements of the same class by a line
like
this okay and and they had these
diagrams that was they had it's a long
story which is which you can read about
in another one of my facles but anyway
this U this is another way to describe a
set Partition by by by having these
little comb like objects uh for for the
for the classes of
and now if um if you can draw these
without Crossing each other that's
called
nesting and so what's happen what does
it mean when you have nesting that so so
so uh so you have nesting you know this
is nested inside of this is nested
inside of this well this means that i1
is equivalent to J1 and I2 is equivalent
to J2 and I3 is equivalent to j3 so you
have um uh you you have you have
elements of the uh so there are Rooks i1
J1 you know i1 J1 I2 J2 I3 j3
um uh where the uh I are going up and
the J's are going
down and there's this uh this other
place in the middle here where where
we're looking at the rectangle so so
when we're looking at a rectangle that
sits between I3 and j3 we see these we
see these three r looks and so we see an
increasing sequence I mean a a
decreasing sequence here the JS are
going down but if I have um
uh if I have the other way where I have
Crossings so so the so here I have you
know i1 is equivalent to J1 and I2 is
equivalent to J2 I3 is equivalent to j3
uh and these are crossing
now um it's the opposite of of nesting
uh it's you know instead of nesting
means it's not intersecting here it
means it's it's it's definitely it's
definitely intersecting it's definitely
Crossing and so you have a Crossing so
what happens is in the duel the whenever
you have H uh you know five things
nested within each other uh then the
original must have had five things
Crossing mutually Crossing each other
and so so so this magical operation
converts nestings to Crossings it and
and and uh
and so it's very U uh uh remarkable in
that way so it preserves
the you know it preserves the the number
of of partitions but it convert the
number of blocks of the partition but it
but but Duality changes nesting to
Crossing
um in every rectangle uh so so you keep
the statistics how many rectangles have
have so have have a maximum increasing
you know have have have so many nestings
and how many have this these statistics
are preserved by this this dual
construction but AB but it's it it was
amazing to people that they should that
should be any connection whatsoever
between nesting and Crossing they seem
like totally uh uh totally different
concepts well um now let me let me uh uh
uh show you some some some more stuff um
let's take uh special special cases of
set partition um one important special
case of a set partition is a matching
this is a matching is where all the
blocks are size two you divide the set
and into
pairs okay that's a matching um so so
this theorem applies to matchings it
says that if I have any matching I can
find a sequence of integer partition
vacillating Tableau Loop that describes
this matching and its dual will also be
a
matching uh because why the property of
a matching is that every element is
either uh the smallest of a block or the
largest of a
block and it's the smallest of a block
if and only if its row is zero and it's
the largest of a block if and only if
its column is zero so that's preserved
by Duality the the the whether the row
and common zero so so every um so so the
Dual of a of a matching
is is a matching not only is dual a
matching is a matching a dual a matching
has the same elements that are the
smallest in their block as it has as
elements that are largest in their block
let's take a
random matching let's see I have do I
have one here I tried to I I tried
to a matching well um I think I do have
one
yeah well
um
so uh yeah here it
is
um here I here I have an example of a
matching so there's two zeros two ones
two tws three two 3es two fours and I
described them by by these Rooks five
these five
Rooks and um uh you'll notice that uh
there's uh uh
there's three three of these Crossing
each other
here now when I take the duel I I get
this matching and you'll notice that
that there are three nested uh uh pairs
here zero the ones inside of the zeros
and the two inside of the one the three
crosses the zero however and um uh well
um uh the number three doesn't have to
necessarily correspond to the number
three on that side uh this one is nested
inside of this one so it's probably this
two is the one that corresponds to three
over on this side because this one this
two is is is U uh Crossing with this guy
but it's nesting on on this one anyway
uh there's there's an an example but you
see the the guys who are smallest in
their lock um um um this one this one
this one this one and this one are are
the same as the guys who are smallest in
the block over here so some and and and
the guys who are highest in the block
have already have also change places but
it's they change places in a rather
strange strange way um I haven't psyched
it out although I do have something that
I found an hour ago well no 3:30 two
hours ago uh uh that I'm going to show
you in a minute um so anyway matchings
however give you one nice uh uh
application of this saying that nested
matchings and uh correspond to uh one to
one somehow with a a cross crosses of
matching um now a special case of
matchings is bipartite
matching bipartite matching where I have
two n elements and I say I'm going to
all match everything in the lower half
to the to to to one of the guys in the
upper half
and uh those are the same as
permutations uh if it's it's easy to see
that you know if I suppose I number the
the guys at the bottom I call them 1 2 3
4 5 and the guys at the top I call them
6 7 8 9 10 well every permutation of 6 7
8 9 10 is a way to match 1 2 3 4 5 to to
you know to the to so so there are um so
uh another special case of this is
permutations every permutation has has a
dual
permutation um and that means it um that
really I'm just um uh you know have a
set partition uh but but in a very
special case that all the Rooks are
actually going in this Square part up
here and so I just put you know I just
put some I just put Rooks here in some
in in some permutation and then I get a
uh a bipar matching
okay so I um we get then the notion of
Duality
between of
permutation and U so there are six
permutations of three elements do this
show here okay um and here's what the
here's what the DU are and you might
think it's clear what what's happening
well the identity permutation goes into
this uh opposite one and these things
sort of seem to rotate um um I think
it's bog me I I I here's a list of all
the 24
presentations um and their duels and uh
uh if you if you can csy out what the uh
what it means uh uh please let me know I
think it's uh I think it's
just it's a it's a total mystery
although very simple you can work out
that you know you can find the Tableau
you can you can you can uh transpose
them and you get the and you get the
duel and uh you can use my vacillate
program and feed in you know bipartite
uh uh matchings and you'll get the dual
partition it'll it'll tell you what they
are um and um how I I I found one one
nice thing about the Duel of a partition
um and that is uh if you well I found
eight nice things about them uh well
seven um if if if you rotate uh this
Square by 90° its duel also rotates by
90° and if you flip it left and right
it's it's its duel also flips so so
although I although we Define the the
concept of Duel By working uh sort of
only look looking upward uh and you know
only we we're only looking north and
west as we're as we're doing this
Duality process actually U the the
algorithm is nice enough mathematically
that it's going to actually you know uh
we could have been been attacking it
from any of the any of the directions so
so all the eight symmetries of the
square uh are preserved under this so so
The Duality commutes with uh uh with the
uh
uh the
um the the symmetries of the square the
left reflection up and down uh rotation
so
um by five for instance what you just
made the observation or you proved this
I proved it yes here's the proof um uh
the proof is uh actually you see if a
corresponds to B then it's reversal left
to right reversal uh corresponds U and
this is by theorem 514d Part
B okay volum three and uh and it's
easier to say if if a corresponds to B
then their transpose correspond to
transposes and this is because it's well
known that the that the um that the Chen
said algorithm if you transpose the
permutation you interchange p and Q and
so so it has to be um so so all you're
doing is is is interchanging p and Q and
and if p is being transposed and Q is
being transposed well anyway this is the
this I believe is the proof so um um the
um uh but here I I show an example of a
sort of a random uh uh 7 by7 permutation
uh and it's dual and I you know I just
don't don't as far as I know uh it's it
it's a a complete mystery as to what as
to this magical operation what it is and
so you know uh but we we know partial
information now I tried one funny thing
I tried an 8 by8 and um and I and all of
the examples I had before when they were
when when I change Rooks to Queens uh uh
it the duel will also work now was a
solution to the Queens problem and I
took the duel and the duel was also a
solution to the Queen's problem oh no
this can't be true and and sure enough
it wasn't uh uh uh uh and and here's um
here's an example of a thing where
there's no Rooks in the same diagonal as
well and the and the duel definitely
didn't work but the first time I I did
it I I I I was uh you know I thought my
gosh what is going on here uh but no
it's not that good um but the uh but
there but this mysterious Duality on on
permutation I mean I uh is is there and
U um the um uh the law it the rule is
that it's uh uh its duel is sort of
related to something that's described in
in my discussion of insertion
of sh and B's uh uh transformation on
tblo has is is related to this anyway
that's but but that's still uh I don't I
don't see anything uh geometric that and
and you see every permutation that has
uh um an increasing sequence of like you
know X's going upward three of them here
there's got to be three of them coming
downward in the duel um and you could
get that effect by tipping the thing
over but that's not the
duel
um okay question this um the Dual
preserve uh anything about this
decomposition of the permutation into
Cycles I don't
know be worth
trying I haven't I haven't uh I you know
I uh if you look at the date of this
sheet it's it's today I I I I was just
thinking about this you know uh just
before lunch so um I well the identity
The Duel is the the ID that's right
that's the identity goes into the rever
into the reverse so so doesn't preserve
the CLE structure it doesn't preserve
the cycle structure but it maybe uh the
sum of the two is constant or something
I mean you know maybe something about
the number of inversions you know
there's all kind of statistics about
permutations that might might might not
be transformed in interesting ways by
this
property uh okay now um
so uh uh um I did find something uh and
that is U another important kind of
matching is a matching with no nestings
at all I mean no no Crossings at all and
these are the non-crossing uh thing
these are for example of matching with
no Crossings is uh is is nested
parenthesis uh you match the left
parenthesis with the right parenthesis
right so so uh uh I take um uh uh a
random binary
tree uh which I don't know where I put
it I thought I brought it with me but I
don't seem to
have that's a shame well um I've got I
do have the uh example
though okay so uh take
up so yeah here's a restricted growth
string for for a uh a set of nest
parenthesis where there's two zeros two
ones two twos and so on so think of the
two zeros as a left and right
parenthesis two ones as left and right
parenthesis the two twos here so so this
describes some big nested sequence of
parenthesis I'm using heximal notation
here to get the a
a because they ran out of of digits
after nine um okay
that's that's a um
um nested parenthesis like this and the
two go in here and the threes go here
and the fours there and so on everything
is nicely nested all right so now we can
we can apply the algorithm and we can we
can find what's the duel and the
duel
um it
has only Crossings no nesting at all and
so the duel is you know 01 zero the one
ones cross the twos the twos come here
the threes cross the fours cross and and
so on well
uh I looked at this and and um I
compared it to the original and it's
very simple what happened here now I've
matched every I've matched the first
left parenthesis to the first left
parenthesis the second left first right
parenthesis the first the second left
parenthesis the second right parenthesis
in other words as you run through long
as you run along this uh this thing here
uh you can you you keep this the
unpaired in a stack and uh and then when
you get to when you get to a right
parenthesis you output the top of the
stack um but now if you use a q instead
of a stack so you output from the bottom
instead thr first INF first out instead
of last and first out then you get the
um the only Crossing and and no nesting
version okay so that's now sub I know
for for this kind of matching I know
exactly what the duel is the duel is
difference between a stack and a
q all right now uh so I Tred but I know
that there's another way to
represent uh uh Forest not only with not
not not with parenthesis but instead you
you consider the um uh two things are
equivalent if and only if they have the
same
parent and that turns out to be a
non uh non-crossing partition of a set
if if if if if you you are equivalent to
your
siblings um so if so so anybody who's
between you and your siblings I mean
this is in
pre-order so anybody's between you and
your siblings uh they aren't going to
have any other siblings that that
separate you from your brothers so so
other words there's no
Crossings if if you list the nodes of a
of a forest in pre-order and you say
that two things are equivalent if
they're if they have if if they're
brothers or sisters uh then that's that
that equivalence relation is is one that
doesn't have any Crossings all right and
uh so here's an example of such a one um
I I I can
um well
uh so so it's not going to have a
crossing the twos there are three TW
though it's it's not a matching cuz cuz
cuz some some some of these sets have
have more but now we now we find the U
uh The Duel of this and again it's
like changing a stack to a cube and so
um uh I uh decided that that was
um
uh this this example was too easy so I
so I took another one and here so here's
a case of a of a um
uh a
non-crossing this is a non-crossing set
partition it's not a matching but it's a
non-crossing set partition uh that's uh
and you can see the restrict I just
wrote the restricted growth string down
here so you see this is there 0 0 0 0 U
nested inside between the first two
zeros is the ones but there's no ones
Crossing it inside of the ones there's
some twos here inside between these two
zeros there's threes between these two
zeros I got four and then some fives and
sixes inside of the fours but I but I
know threw in stuff but I wasn't going
to have any any uh any Nest any Crossing
and uh you can see it in the you you can
see it in the X's because if I if you
take any one of these rectangles you
take take any point on the boundary here
and and look at the at the Rooks that
that that are above and to the left
there's never going to be um uh an
upward pair of Rooks there's no you know
this this had if if there was an upward
pair that would be a crossing and so
there's no Crossings in this in this set
partition so now say well what is the
Dual of this set partition and the
answer is
this I sorted all the X's into
order um basically you out you know
where wherever there's an x uh you you
you you drop it down to the lowest
possible place and and sort them so that
they all they all go like this now you
have only
Crossings um now it it's what was a
little funny because you here's this x
sitting way up here it it it must you
know you go from here and you get to the
Duel of this it gives you this one um uh
so U it's not as uh as as as simple as
as you might think that the the way this
happens but here we are uh uh you see
the Duel of of a non- nested thing is
always looking pretty nice it it um uh I
haven't proved this I mean this is an
observation I made at 3:30 this
afternoon so but I believe it must be
true because I took a pretty random
example right it's got to be true so so
other we can understand
non-crossing um uh the Duels of of
non-crossing set
partition now another thing I looked at
was self-dual set partitions this is
cute I I don't have time to to tell you
much about it but the number of du you
know they equal their own duel uh the
number of them is a Fibonacci number the
it goes uh you know f f sub 2N minus one
is the number of selfdual set partitions
and here I've I've WR written the 34
cases when uh Nal 5 U and I found a
Wonder to one correspondence with uh Mor
code sequences which is known to be the
Fibonacci number it's it's it's a tricky
correspondence it's not real simple but
uh but I think it's the best you can do
um and uh so uh these are the cases now
but self-d set partition is something
where uh the uh the lambdas uh uh have
to equal their transpose so the only
possible lambdas are zero and one so
that means that we never get more than
one Rook at a time in our window to the
left and and um and uh so now um uh this
uh suggests that you know the
well there's a
million problems suggested by all this
stuff but one of the things is let we
can talk about the width of a of a set
partition and that is how big do the how
many Rooks are there ever present at one
at once as you're marching along you
know can and and is there presumably you
know we could find out how you know this
is the case where the width is equal to
Z or one um is the selfdual case but
what if I consider all set partitions of
width too how many of them are there how
many you know that's an enumeration
problem that that begs to be uh solved
um
uh it's got to grow eventually because
uh I mean for fixed width it's it can
very well be a a simply exponential
growth but the uh the total number of
set partitions grows faster than n
factorial because it well okay so um
uh here's here's
a final thing I wanted to tell you is
that all of this is still a special case
of much more General stuff and that is
instead of say instead of talking on set
partitions let us talk about an
arbitrary um uh placement of Rooks on
any shape of board
whatsoever so now I take another shape
of
board and uh uh suppose for example I
take the one I had before
six 3 4 5 six and then what was it 4
311 okay now um
I um I consider all the ways to put
Rooks in this board
uh this is a problem that uh it's known
to known to have a lot of interesting
theory that a
Garcia they call it worked out the the
it's called Rook polinomial are are are
related to this
anyway now walk along the edge of this
diagram here I'm going to the right up
up right right up right up right okay
now I'm going to generalize a
vacillating
tableau to a to to a sequence of Tableau
that starts with zero ends with zero but
when I take a rightward step I'm allowed
to add add a rook when I take an upward
step I'm allowed to subtract a rook but
instead of going up across up you know
left you right up right up right up
right up here I'm doing it another
sequence so now I'm saying that Lambda
you know Lambda 1 can be bigger than
Lambda 0 Lambda 2 can be smaller than
Lambda 1 Lambda 3 can be smaller than
Lambda 2 here I'm allowed to go up here
I'm allowed to go up here and allowed to
go down okay so there's a one to one
correspondence between all work
placements in this shape and a sequence
of integer partitions that have the up
and up and down steps confined to the to
that
place again each one of these work
placements has a duel
corresponding to taking the transpose of
all those partitions because those
partitions will do the the transpose of
the partitions will do the same
thing and the duel depends on the the
boundary that I showed here if I if I
take the duel with respect to to a
bigger boundary it it might it it it
might move move the Rooks around so for
every class of of Rook polom for every
class of Rook placements we have a one
to1 correspondence with uh uh certain
integer sequence of inte sequences of
integer partitions and though and and
the the one1 correspondence is has the
property that it preserves um uh you
know that that that that there's a
duality operation on it that uh has
miraculous uh uh properties and uh uh
that is um uh pretty mind-blowing so so
you see what now maybe why I decided to
add another page and a half to volume
four when I when I heard about this I
had to have I had to have this in there
although I'm sure after a year goes by a
lot more will be known about this about
this kind of
thing um um then uh I was working with
Christian caler when we said well now
let's let's generalize this further not
to just allowing only one rook in a row
but let's allow you know several things
in a in a row and
and uh and pretty soon we found out that
if we generalize
it enough we would ReDiscover theorems
of foin that came out five years ago um
in other words uh uh if you look at this
whole thing I said today um with a
really uh special Viewpoint and not see
any of the special of the simple special
cases you would find out that um that uh
a very general theory of uh of um of
Tableau um that was published some time
ago actually gives us these results if
you if you specialize specialize
specialize specialize down so it it it's
it's just the moral is in mathematics
very often
um um you get a general theorem you
don't really understand it until you
find many many special cases of it
because it's very hard when you when
you're given a problem to know what
general theorem is this a special I mean
there's there's there's a huge number of
specializations of any theorem and so
when you learn a new theorem try to find
simple cases of it and and and often
you'll find out that that tells you
something new about those simple cases
so so in a way this
was this this whole theory was was
contained in another generalization but
that generalization was so complicated
nobody could could really perceive that
it included this special case or all of
these special cases I've been talking
about okay thanks a lot for
listening any more
questions
original correspondence between set
partitions and sequences of these yeah
right that's what was the what what's
one carry away striking feature of set
partitions that follows from this
Duality uh because I I didn't hear one
that I thought wow you know that's
really well the most striking was about
the connect uh the nesting with respect
to Crossing because because set
partitions I mean the nesting properties
of set partitions are are uh
uh some of the most important things
about them the the the fact yeah the
fact that the U um I mean there was a
sequence of people had been studying
properties of of of
matchings and then it turned out that
that the Stanley and these four other
people said well but it also applies to
set
partitions and so so in the special case
of matchings uh the uh the connection
between matchings with different kind of
nesting and so on was the uh was the uh
uh the orig spark to studying
this now the other thing was just the
fact that there was that integer
partitions and set partitions have this
connection that was without without
respected Duality I thought was um uh
was uh pretty remarkable as well yeah
you come some of the uh there are
self-dual set partitions now if we go
down the specialization chain you then
specialize to matchings it looks like
there will be selfdual matchings right
if you match everybody to its adjacent
one
um uh certainly and then and then the
next question is are there selfdual
permutations no no okay no no you can't
have a self-d permutation um the uh uh
the
um let's see why is that trivial
um because
what can't have a
rectangle no I mean okay you can't have
a permutation that has a that that has
uh that has a
corresponding
um
uh partition bigger than
one the number of Rooks in the rectangle
is the so so there is a self-d
permutation but it's only in the case n
equals
n equals 2 you're already building a a
tableau that has two elements in it so
its transpose is going to be
different the the partitions all have to
be self conj have to be self- conjugate
and and and when when and there's no
self- conjugate partition of of of two
elements if you could go from one to
three then we could have self dual thing
but then we need a different problem
where we have more than one rook in a in
a row
there are self there are self-dual
matchings in fact um uh I've shown all
all the um my Fibonacci construction
here these are the self to set
partitions and so uh well these are on
five elements so uh you'd have to go to
an even number of elements in order to
get a matching but but the self-d
involutions in other words involution is
a matching with other Singleton elements
as
well
I yeah I'm not sure probably uh take
five minutes to find out how many self-d
matchings there
are